how do you feel when you watch yourself
i mean are you an actor because
sometimes actors hate watching
themselves they loathe
you hate it
even when you were young even when you
were young
torture no i could appreciate certain
things i could appreciate certain things
but then i would bum myself out because
i then work with the new generation of
saved by the belt the new cast and i
really and i go god they were they're so
much more [ __ ] talented than i ever
was back then like
why did i
why did my career go the way it did
from that like
that to me was mediocre compared to what
these new with this new generation is
doing um so i look at it at that point
like i i say i could have done that
better i could have taken it more
serious um
i
i try to learn from things but i don't i
learn from experiences on set i don't
learn from watching myself because then
it just becomes like a
it's already set man it's like you know
i i can't do anything about it right
it's like i'm just gonna go to sleep
grumpy is there something though that
you watched that you go you know what i
was [ __ ] good in that you know what i
appreciate my work in that there is yeah
oh yeah yeah what is that
you recall i i really like pitch when i
was on pitch i really liked that show
um i like the passage i like some of my
work that i've done recently even on mix
dish there were some funny things that i
thought
um
i kind of got right uh there's a lot i
still you know feel like i got wrong but
um
i think it's easier to watch myself if
i'm playing a character
if you know i'm sure it's the same for
you if you're outside of michael yeah
and you're playing a complete character
i can't judge it as much because
you know it's and i and i i guess i look
back at like say by the bell and that
was a character that wasn't me i wasn't
a cool kid i didn't even have blonde
hair i mean i was you know i'm a
my mother's indonesian my father is
dutch
um
i i have uh i come from a mixed family
and i'm playing the whitest kid in
america
you know that's true and it's
and but you think like oh i look back
and say oh that's a character but i i
just some of the choices that i made
um
with the dialogue i i just feel i could
have done better but did you have a lot
of experience before then with acting
not really i mean commercials and stuff
yeah so what do you mean it's you can't
be that hard on yourself when you really
hadn't done anything except for
commercials
but look at these kids nowadays look at
these kids i mean
just watch any show that has a kid on it
and they're amazing like they they have
such talent
not only that they're they're they're
acting they're sane they're dancing
they're they're just entertainers but
don't you think some of it has to do
with the how it's written
the quality of the work i mean you guys
are saved by the bell no offense but it
was like kind of fluff fun
you know
right you don't say that michael you
know i got in trouble one time for
saying that well i remember uh it's a
difference no i agree with you i agree
with you right i totally agree with you
but 12 years ago i had said
that the work i did on saved by the bell
was not breaking bad
you know basically saying that the
writing was not breaking bad well
am i right i mean anybody would say tell
you you're right
oh i gotta i i remember being on a
bicycle ride after i said that i said it
in some
you know press line or something i was
on a bicycle ride
and some
buddy from tmz
uh got my number and called me and i i
didn't even know you know back then i
just picked up the phone hello
uh would you like to um you know comment
on on your comments
say it by the bell because you know
it sounds like you're in great i'm
ungrateful for
your experience i trust oh [ __ ] no
no no it's not what it meant of course
that's not what you meant it's just
obvious it's like this is a a kids show
this was the what was it the 80s the 90s
it was just kind of it was on early it
wasn't written for like a darker
we get it